and how to you saw expert help with some
questions and you went to really
top-notch experts you went to astronaut
Chris Hadfield yeah because you had very
specific areas just to prove that we
have a photo of him don't know why that
popped up you wanted you wanted his
advice wouldn't what it's the questions
that you wanted him to answer well I was
doing a chapter on how to make an
emergency landing and I wanted to try
covering all of the like weird scenarios
that might not be covered in a normal
guide to you know flying a plane so I
came up with a list of all of the
strangest like things that might happen
to you
scenarios where you need to land a plane
and and he was really nice and willing
to answer my questions so I made I made
this list of scenarios and I ordered
them from least ridiculous to most
ridiculous and my plan was to see how
far I could get through the list before
he hung up on me
so you start up pretty simple like if
I'm in a plane and I have to land it
what would be the but then you get more
and more ridiculous in terms of the
criteria yeah yeah well I started off
with what I thought was kind of maybe
maybe the least ridiculous of them which
was if you have to land a plane and you
can't find any landing strips or like
you know roads and the only open cities
are farmers fields which crop do you try
to steer toward which crop yeah like you
know you've got you've got your sorghum
and your corn your and so I asked so I
asked him this question and and the most
fun thing about talking to Colonel
Hadfield is he's you know he's he's like
a gnat he's everything he says sounds
like it's in that Mission Control
astronaut voice yeah you know and he's
and so I asked that question and no
hesitation at all you know I like sort
of apologize like sorry I know it's kind
of a ridiculous question no hesitation
at all he just says well that's not a
ridiculous question at all I fly small
planes and you think about that stuff
all the time when you're driving into
the airfield you look around and you
think if I had to come down there could
I are there cows out in their field
today how higher their beans and then he
started rattling off crops and what
times of year it was safe to crash-land
in them
so apparently example well I remember he
said corn is okay up until about the
middle of June then they've got more you
said because I read the book she said
you asked him did he hang up on this one
you said what would happen if I had to
land the plane but my sleeve was stuck
in the door and I couldn't reach the
control panel is that correct yeah yeah
and I answer that so I the the wonderful
talking him was so much fun because he
never paused before any of these
questions he liked before answering he
was never like well I don't know about
he would just like here's what I would
do like I guess that's if you're a you
know world class test pilot yeah but
yeah so I said what if your sleeves
caught in the cockpit door and you can't
reach the controls but you've got
something like maybe dinner rolls from
the in-flight meals that you can throw
at them could you could you if you were
really good at throwing the dinner rolls
could you land just by hitting the right
controls and and he I think he asked
right away like well is this a
single-engine plane or a multiple engine
plane and he said because in a
single-engine plane uh no I don't think
so but in a multiple engine plane here's
what you might be able to do and then he
started laying out a landing procedure
like based on if you have this many
dinner rolls and you're really good at
like ricocheting them how you could
nudge the throttles to conceivably have
a chance of bringing it down so that's
fantastic I love that I love that I
couldn't stump him I know probably he
would ask like are these rolls a little
stale that would help they're a little
stale they'll have more mass I can hit
the button harder yeah yeah he he would
right away like always come up with like
I asked him I was like what if he wanted
to sell as many parts of the plane as
you could on like Craigslist before
landing but you had to deliver them
before you land so you're gonna be like
you need stuff you can throw overboard
but then still make your landing
and it turns out he knew exactly which
parts of the plane you could these like
well you can the seats you know the food
from the meals you can probably get
money for those you can get all the
anything in luggage anything in the
baggage or compartment that's something
someone paid to transport it's probably
worth money to throw that overboard and
and then and then he started saying but
the thing is when you're pulling out the
seats and throwing them overboard you
can't just start at the back and move
forward because the center balance of
the plane will tip too far for ya I
can't believe it
and you want you this long yeah and he
should have hung up on you at this point
well that's it so so yeah it I was I was
surprised because he kept going he
actually um when we had this
conversation I don't think I mentioned
this in the book but the reason we had a
certain amount of time to talk was he
was on a layover between two flights so
his end of this conversation was
actually happening in an airport
terminal and and so I started realizing
oh we're running out of time I should
start giving him an opening to hang up
you know to go and I was like well thank
you so much for all these answers you
know it's and then he got to go for your
flight and he would just say oh that's
fine we haven't called my group number
yet I can keep going you know yeah like
it took me a while to realize because
you know astronauts and come across as
very serious sometimes but it's like oh
he's actually really really enjoying
this is a fun permit so yeah he
continued to answer my questions I think
as he walked down the jet way with the
other passengers and boarded the plane
right and I feel at that point I sort of
I think I sort of hung up on him because
because all I could think was like oh no
those poor people on that plane who are
gonna hear him like walking down he's
like well if I were trapped on the
outside of the plane I think I try to
work my way back to the tail he's not
putting people at ease yeah but man
there there is there is no plane that
was safer than the one that has him on
it yeah in know what they encountered
it's in my contract I only fly with him
okay what I can't believe is that you
got Serena Williams to help you with one
of your thought experiments yeah I
didn't I didn't expect that to work
either I was I was working on I had a
chapter on how to catch a drone or how
to shoot down a drone if it's you know
you got one of those like wedding
photography drones they obviously flying
around and I said okay well what do you
do if there's one just floating over
your yard and you're you're like I don't
know who's flying this thing I want to
get rid of it
and there are all these cool ideas
people have for anti-drone
countermeasures and different tools and
stuff that you know you can do but I was
curious what if you just have like the
normal stuff in your shed like and so I
started going through sports equipment
because I was thinking what what would
be better for shooting a drone a
basketball or a baseball because you
know a baseball seems like you can throw
harder and maybe more accurately but
like a basketballs bigger so so I ended
up because I tend to like go on these
deep dives I started like building up
this mathematical model of like
projectiles thrown by people in
different sports and how accurate they
are at hitting arbitrary targets and so
I was getting all these papers on like
like accuracy of you know a football
yeah in football and like hockey and
baseball and stuff and I couldn't find
great data on tennis I could you know I
couldn't find a good paper that would
like compare to the other you know shada
that I was using and so kind of on a
whim I mean I reached out to Serena
Williams and was like hey I'm working on
this cool thing I'm working on this
thing and and and and I had known her
husband from way back when and so I
reached out and and asked if she would
be interested if if she wanted to try
hitting a target for me to to just give
me data to put into this model because
most of the studies I was using were
based on like world-class athletes and
so so and and and it turned out she was
like more than happy to help and was
like yeah what do you need and so I was
like okay I don't want to take too much
of her time you know this is and I don't
want to give like complicated you know
like something that's gonna like take
them a while to set up and then not work
out right or whatever so I was like okay
maybe just if you can if you can put a
target have someone sticker like a
masking tape X on the wall sometime when
you're at practice and just tell me how
far you are from the target and like and
and serve try
trying to get the ball as close as you
can to the target and videotape it then
I can like use that to feed into my
model but it turns out she came back
with like asked if I wanted the of one
of her to just hit a drone and she knew
ultimately that's what you're trying to
figure out who's like I'm sure I just
hit a drill and I was like that would
also work yeah
and so so they got a really this nice
photography drone that had a broken
camera so it was just sitting around and
they were willing to sacrifice it for
science or I mean science like easy
they're real yeah yeah to answer a
question that I am trying to answer
through scientific means you know like
through through rigorous analysis um to
get me data to feed into the model so
she did she they put a drone up
yeah they flew it over the court uh had
someone fly it and she stood behind the
the baseline I'm like had it hovering
over the net and we have footage oh yes
awesome let's take a look
yeah oh great yeah that was great
that I don't that skews the curve she'd
be better at that when I was meeting I
had I had so I had my model that was
like based on what data I could find
that had suggested that it would take a
tennis pro my estimate was that it would
take from that distance with that model
drone like five to seven serves to score
a hit and she got it on her third serve
yeah so I don't know if that says just
statistical outlier or if it's just just
Serena Williams outlier I sort of think
that's that one let's give it to Serena
yeah Raina's book how to absurd
scientific advice for common real-world
problems is out now so cool to talk to
you thanks for all you do thank you
[Applause]